hello everyone and greetings from Peru
first thank you to lab roots and the
sponsors for the opportunity to present
to you the work that we're carrying out
in Lima Peru my name is Paulo Tsukiyama
and I'm assistant professor of
microbiology at manure theory Parihaka
Eaton Arabia and Institute for tropical
medicine in Lima the work I'm going to
tell you about is on an ongoing outbreak
of KCl and ammonia infections that also
happen to the current panel resistance
have provided a great challenge to
clinicians down there and how we are
using genomics technologies and
bioinformatics to understand the
transmission dynamics of these pathogen
but first why clip CLN money and why
carabiner resistance well because it is
a very complicated pathogen that caused
a lot of problems in hospitals worldwide
the CDC back in 2013 determined that it
is an urgent threat to public health and
this is because certain strains of
Klebsiella worldwide are becoming more
virulent are becoming increasingly
resistant to antibiotics which is
something we don't only see in capsular
but also in many other pathogenic
bacteria this slide right here shows you
a time line in blue of the year when an
antibiotic class was first deployed
throughout the 20th century and in red
is the year when clinicians started
seeing resistance in a clinic to the
same antibiotics as you can see for all
of them antibiotic resistance eventually
developed over time in just a matter of
5 10 15 years so it's not really a
matter of whether resistance will happen
is when it will happen
and this is the case for all antibiotics
in recent decades to compound the
problem if
fact that we have not many new
antibiotic classes in the pipelines in
the research pipelines and it is because
the golden era of antibiotics which
happened sometime in the sixties and
seventies is really now long gone we
discovered most of the antibiotic
classes that I use today and everything
then we have not been able to keep that
pace of discovery of new classes and
instead what we've been using in recent
decades is the modification targeted
modification of existing antibiotic
black box that's how to any feelings
over the course of many generations of
development turning into the third or
fourth generation panda feelings like
lip wrestling same philosophy loves
pourings setting for tetracyclines and
so over the years we are able to develop
new variants of these molecules that
somehow overcome structure systems that
evolved in intelligence so we cannot do
this indefinitely at some point we run
out of new variant and thirteen classes
of antibiotics become obsolete and a
very worrying report came out of the UK
from five years ago we determine the
burden the economic burden and social
burden of microbial resistance if things
stay the same if it's business as usual
for everyone for business and government
throughout the world nowadays
antimicrobial resistance leads to about
700,000 deaths annually if ins continue
the rate they are these may reach 210
million deaths per year by 2050 to put
that in perspective this is more than
all other causes of that combined so Amr
antimicrobial resistance is set to
become the leading cause of death if we
don't take measures against it now
really
also to make things worse is the fact
that we are using more and more
antibiotics over the years the study I
came out a year ago
comparing worldwide consumption and
prescription of antibiotics and we see
that in red
most countries from the global south and
emerging economies have increased the
antibiotics used by significant amount
after economies become better over time
and this is to show you a graph that
depicts that upper middle income
countries in particular countries like
Peru in South America show and will show
the greatest increase in antibiotics use
as their economies develop this is a
good thing for economies because they
can treat antibiotics better but in the
end this might lead to selection of
antibiotic of antimicrobial resistance
another factor that influences the
spread of antimicrobial resistance
worldwide is that genes and pathogens
human populations migrate very rapidly
this is the case of the KPC and NDM
karabiner resistance mechanisms that
originated KPC in the United States in
an mid-2000s and a few years later NPM
emerged in the Indians continent because
of travel and movement of pathogens and
humans these mechanisms quickly became
disseminated at worldwide scales and so
lead us to these graphs where we see the
different variants of corrupt animators
are now endemic or reported in multiple
sites across the world
take a look closer look at South America
you will see that at least this study
from six years ago describes a kpc was
endemic in Latin America there was no
sample we'll give you an update of that
how is it how is it that bacteria become
so resistant so rapidly it shouldn't be
a surprise at all because
bacteria are really experts at
exchanging and procreating genes two
mechanisms of horizontal gene transfer
these are conjugation for instance
transformation transduction that leads
to the movement of genes of a certain
gene of many genes very rapidly across
exterior genomes even of a related
bacterial species is something and only
bacteria can do and makes them very
adaptable and very able to respond to
antimicrobial pressures in the
environment so they quickly become
persistent and this persistence
phenotypes spread across material
populations how is it that we study
bacteria and how they become resistant
nowadays we're in the midst of
revolution based on next-generation
sequencing DNA DNA sequencing has over
the years become increasingly cheaper
and we are able to have increasing
amounts of raw DNA sequence being
analyzed this is thanks to technologies
from the likes of Illumina and Oxford
nanopore that kind now give us many many
more rates compared to ten years ago at
much lower prices but this means in the
practice is that we are able to sequence
beyond a single organism genome and into
pathogen populations
so this revolution in genomics has
happened in just a few years has led us
to being able to sequence not just a
single organism for a pathogen but an
entire population of diverse organisms
are isolated from between humans and so
that enables the study of outbreaks AG
local international national and local
scales as well as in the long and short
pyramids so now we're able to sequence
the genomes of hundreds or thousands of
isolates of variants of a pathogen
population by determining how is it that
these individual isolates are
transmitted and how they are evolving
over time and over larger distances
these studies started coming out in 2012
this is one of the first ones by the
group of the events meeting and Julia's
angry at the NIH where they studied an
outbreak of Carol Panem - assistant
cliffthea an ammonia it was that led to
fatal consequences in this hospital they
were able to isolate the clip siela
isolates from these patients and to
holding a sequencing were able to
determine the sequence of transmission
events and this despite the
implementation of infection control
procedures at the hospitals that are
meant to limit such infections and this
kept me thinking for a while how would
you how would this work how would an
outbreak of cripsy a lack of inner
resistance would play out in Peru in the
absence of such implementation of
contextual measures because of
constrained budgets or infrastructure
but anyway if authors were able to
determine the sequence of events with
very high confidence determine who pass
the assistance I begin to whom in a
hospital and determinately the sequence
of events from epidemiological and
genomic records
fast forward a few years and these
efforts that were limited to single
institution single hospitals can be
turned into continent-wide surveillance
this study just came out a few months
reporting on 1700 genomes of capsule and
ammonia from all across Europe and they
determine the mechanisms by which happen
and resistance is traveling and in the
end the authors determine that
transmission is driven by nosocomial
infections this is just to show a
phylogenetic tree with those 1700 plus
isolates and how they are classified in
two major sequence types but within
sequenced abuse also see a clear
communication of deeper variation that
can only be achieved at the level of the
genome and read through holding and
sequencing now coming back to Peru and
where we are coming from is that only in
2013 despite these therapy no resistance
in clips HeLa was being reported from a
decade already only in 2013 we start
seeing these cases in the clinic first
reported as individual cases we started
seeing Klebsiella pneumoniae is one
usual suspect and through the KPC and
MDM Jane's as well but it wasn't until
2017 that I moved back to Peru and
started setting up the local genomic
infrastructure before I moved back to
Peru at least in my University in most
of Peru we were not using
next-generation sequencing for these
types of applications so it was our job
to do the initial setup of the genomic
infrastructure at our university but
also we have to deal with the issue of
by automatic analysis which was a great
challenge for us because we lacked the
resources to set up sophisticated
computer classes and that's when the
solution of kig bioinformatics and their
genomics
workbench suits came to help us this is
very well integrated all-in-one solution
for bioinformatic analysis and
especially the microbial genomics module
was really helpful in helping us type
and determine antimicrobial resistance
genes in bacterial genomes so check it
out the latest version is out now with
an updated database of resistant genes
that came very useful in these analysis
so around 2015 our collaborators
technicians at the teaching hospital
next door started dealing with this very
worrying outbreak of Kip Sheila in the
morning that was color panel resistant
and by by definition this means that
they're resistant to most left line
therapy so they are very hard to treat
leading to casualty rates of 30 to 50
percent of all cases so it's very
problematic and we can see that over the
years we see an increase of cases until
the peaking around 2017 but this
outbreak has continued into 2018 and
2019 and so far we have reported about
80 cases in the last two years so it's
been very hard to contain is causing a
lot of problems and a lot of fatalities
and morbidity down in this hospital
it came from a different variety of
sources of types of infection and from
many different services in hospital but
mainly from the intensive care unit the
ICU was at the center of this outbreak
as if usually the case in these
outbreaks the intensive care unit holds
patients that are who have weak immune
systems and many times the the hacking
protocols are breached so it's very easy
for outbreaks to start in these settings
for this one particular hospital this is
based in the north of Lima which serves
some of the poorest population
the city he has been recently renovated
probably ten years ago this is how it
looks like what the first thing you will
notice is that patient isolation is not
possible and that usually this I see
used should be working at 80% capacity
but given the high demand from this
hospital it's always working at full
capacity making it even more likely that
pathogens will transmit between patients
there is a some degree of isolation but
not much
personnel nurses are limited in this so
that many many nurses are seeing
multiple patients at a time all these
factors can influence the transmission
of pathogens in these settings there is
some degree of isolation for the most
critical patient that's not total
isolation as you would expect in
countries or hospitals that have more
resources for these and starting from
two years ago now we because the
outbreak has been recognized
now there's daily sampling of surfaces
and patients for surveillance studies in
the end we isolated clip CL any money
from any side from these patients and
this is what we eventually ended up with
single isolates of capsule and ammonia
that were used for genome sequencing so
we collected about 18 capsular isolates
from 59 patients from it from the first
two three years of the outbreak and
these were all sequence last year in our
aluminum Issac instrument using the
standard NextEra xt library prep we
multiplex around 24 genomes per run
which leads to a coverage of about 20 80
X for every single base Regina this is
enough sequencing depth to be able to
type and differentiate between closely
isolated cases as mentioned earlier we
use the CFE genomics work bench and the
CSE microeconomics module to
to handle these genomes to take us all
the way from raw reads we train them the
quality control we can do special
species identification working local
sequence type in and from there start
building our genetic trees using camera
based methods for quick reference trees
or using a snip based trees for high
resolution comparisons of related
isolates we can also perform the novel
assembly and from those assemblies by
antibiotic resistant genes using the
risk finder application and as mentioned
earlier caging just came out with a new
curated database of microbial resistance
gene has proven very useful for these
types of analyses
first things first we have to compare
how all these clips Allah isolates are
related to each other and this is a
k-mer tree that was based on the
Illumina sequence reads and he there's a
lot of information and these and this
map but I'll guide you through it first
thing is that well we've started seeing
some differences in all Christian
Latinos he was immediately apparent that
we were not dealing with a single cloud
that has been very successful in this
setting in many cases of Adwords
a single clone can overtake and cause
epidemics but it is not the case we see
a lot of genetic diversity in this date
of it to the point that it was not just
keep CL and ammonia single species but
there were other clips Els species
present for instance in patient 74
differed to isolate for the same patient
we identified two solemnity analysis
these are related
subspecies of kimchi Ella and this was
this was carrying the KTC enzyme later
on we also identified few isolates of
cage Sheila quasi pneumonia again this
is a subspecies bystander phenotypic
methods you wouldn't be able to tell
these apart from capsule a good morning
but it has some unique epidemiological
consequences in fact that we found it
and not just one but two lineages were
found the first in the first three years
at 15 2016 is an unknown sequence that
was carrying KPC - and various patients
at the ICU and ER we're sharing this
variant and there's some evidence of
direct transmission within the hospital
later on 2017
- Taylor crossing and when he came back
this was a different Linnaeus this time
was carrying the NPM enzyme so it
involves separated from the previous one
and was introduced into these
environments as well and the rest the
boat of the isolates actually correspond
to could feel an ammonia but even there
were we found very high diversity
strengthen lineages most of them were in
the n+ and we found many different
sequence types on the left you see that
many 15 cases from the sequence type 45
where reported this was the most
abundant sequence type in our dataset
but we also identify sequence types 2 1
9 SP 11 15 and 147 if last few have been
reported occasionally in Europe and
especially in the Middle East so the
fact that these are all showing up in
Peru talks to how diverse how successful
tipsy la lineages are in disseminating
globally again the conclusion from this
part is that there's multiple lineages
coming into the hospital and some of
them becoming endemic is not just one
lineage that was very successful and
became epidemic but multiple coming in
and setting up residence in this
environment which is worrisome which is
complicated for infection control
measures it's just a graph reminding us
that FP 45 was the most abundant one
followed by 290 147 but in general we
saw a lot of genetic diversity in this
set
if we build a high resolution snip tree
this is based on single nucleotide
polymorphisms against a reference clip
CLA genome and this enables us very high
resolution typing and to determine how
different related i isolate are so to
the right you will see the SP 45
isolates 15 of them and these differ
from each other in just 0 to 4 to 5
snips at a time and that is highly
suggestive of single bacterium being
directly transmitted between patients so
not only we have a lot of diversity
coming in but within the service between
different services this is patients from
the ER in the ICU the strains are being
transmitted by physical contact properly
and we see a similar pattern for SD 147
where we see co2 3 sneeze again
supporting the idea that this is being
transmitted directly between patients in
this hospital if we look further into
the genetic context in which these
persistency are embedded we find
unsurprisingly that these are within the
plasmid environment which allows them to
move very easily between related
lineages so MDM is traveling in three
types three variants of genetic context
all belonging to these inks B family of
plasmids and KPC to also struggling
along all the resistance genes
surrounded my work mobile genetic
elements which force the idea that these
genes travel very easily across
bacterial genomes
not just MDM and kpc are only two the
most important for this case but with we
see very high diversity of resistance
mechanisms in this theater which is not
unexpected
we know that one scripts yella get into
the hospital environment they tend to
accumulate illness factors and
resistance genes so the fact that we see
these multiple levels of assistance is
not surprising but I still worry
in summary I just presented the work on
genomic characterization on carpenter
assistantship CLS in Peru and the whole
genome sequencing data suggests that
these cave CLE lineages have been
introduced multiple occasions multiple
lineages over the 3-4 years since the
outbreak started kpc positive strains
were first reported supporting what's
available in the literature but later on
and vmworld positive lineages we place
these in 2016 and 2017 and became the
dominant lineages in this environment we
found some evidence of the earth
transmission between patients and across
services and infection control measures
have been implemented despite limited
resources and limited infrastructure yet
we have not been contained yet and the
outbreak is still ongoing we have
reported about 80 new cases in 2018 2019
despite some evidence that the cases are
coming down now this is an ongoing
project and we will keep sequencing the
new set of isolates company hopefully
will respond to you at a later date so
that's all the work that we have for
today we have to give many many things
to our collaborators the clinicians
working at this hospital dealing
directly with infection and also to
people in my laboratory at Gaia
generator University where we studied
these and many other bacterial pathogens
that are relevant to Peruvian public
shock
that's it for now thank you for your
time and attention and I'm open to
questions thank you very much
you